[Music]
morning John it's Wednesday August 15th
that's not my song my song is about
something that happened to me a few
weeks ago that sort of changed my life
my life is different now and I started
writing this song back then and now it
is done
[Music]
one Tuesday the farm while I was in bed
I was really interested and what my
brother said he said front page from
page from page holy crap and I was like
dude I've taken a freakin nap and then I
realized and I ran to my laptop and I
stared at it in shock
holy crap I got featured on YouTube
I stared at my face staring back at me
my white my mouth gave I clicked on me
to see man I felt so elated my vid was
highly read it my pronunciation was too
bad but I was glad that I created
something so many people would see and
laugh at me
[Music]
and that's what it was like to get
featured on YouTube this would happen
and I thought that some might be our
chance
next thing I knew 30,000 people want me
to my happy dance
yeah they watch me do my happy dance
I wanna hug every girl and guy that
clicked on subscribe
that video is watched 700 thousand times
in your comments they got me to the most
discussed page even if 20% of them said
I was lame her game but now I know
never be that famous ever again
I just want to say thank you and I want
to say thank you to you and I want to
say thank you to youtube so I don't have
time to write a song about you eating a
blenderize taffy meal because that I'm
sure what's been a very good song but I
just wanted to say thank you to YouTube
big news the into the world that
according to YouTube is this big and
that is as big as it can get that is how
big this news is YouTube has made us
partners and I'm not entirely sure what
that means but there is an orientation
session that Jon and I are going to be
sitting in on I don't know how to
describe cuz I don't know what it is but
I know that's a big deal the sort of
like famous youtubers are partners and
they're making us partners too so maybe
we'll become famous youtubers too maybe
probably not really how could we not be
happy with our already levels of Fame
I mean users being famous but then
there's being famous to cool people and
right now all the people who think that
we're cool are really cool so that's way
better than being famous with like
everybody anyway
Jon I look forward to you finding a cat
to lick I'll see you tomorrow